dans l' affaire de pédophilie danger
neuf personnes trois hommes et six
femmes ont été mises en examen depuis la
semaine dernière pour viol et
proxénétisme aggravé leur victime 27
enfants de 6 mois à 12 ans gregory r ou
des enfants parfois contre un paquet de
cigarette ou un colis de la banque
alimentaire
c'est dans cet appartement notamment que
27 victimes âgés de 6 mois à 6 ans sont
passés de main en main
les faits se dérouler le samedi
après-midi une affaire sordide de
prostitution et d'inceste dans laquelle
neuf personnes ont été mises en examen
la semaine dernière trois hommes et six
femmes des mères de famille complice
motivé par l'argent
une centaine de stèles huit des neuf
personnes en cause sont sous les verrous
placé dans cinq établissements
pénitentiaires de la région
une plainte pour viol déposée par une
jeune fille de 16 ans a permis de mettre
un terme à ces pratiques mais la justice
refuse de parler d'un réseau organisé de
pédophilie on est dans le quart monde
avec des gens qui sont extrêmement
démunies
c'étaient les plus pervers et les plus
agissants qui éventuellement ont essayé
à certains moment de tirer profit des
enfants qui étaient abusés les
enquêteurs cherchent maintenant à
identifier toutes les victimes à
remonter jusqu'aux clients
la semaine prochaine il pourrait
procéder à de nouvelles arrestations